August 2021 saw the first trailer for "No Way
Home" hit the internet, and, suffice to say,
fans absolutely lost their minds. They were
met with returning villains, head-scratching
revelations, and more ... but it wasn't enough.
It didn't take long for the Marvel fandom to
call for a second teaser, and at long last,
Marvel Studios and Sony Pictures have obliged.
Aside from giving us a better sense
of what to expect from the film,
our latest look at "No Way Home" is packed
with small details that you might have missed.
The "No Way Home" trailer was full of interesting
parallels that served as callbacks to former
Spidey flicks. Perhaps the biggest reference to an
older film came toward the end of the trailer when
MJ falls off some scaffolding, and it looks like
Peter may or may not be able to save her in time.
We see their hands almost come together, but we'll
have to wait for the movie to see if MJ is saved.
Fans of "The Amazing Spider-Man 2" were
likely taken back to the tragic moment when
Gwen Stacy dies in the film after falling from
a clocktower. Peter tries his best to save her,
but even though his web latches onto her at the
last second, it doesn't do so in enough time
to prevent her from hitting the ground. The
camera work in "No Way Home" shows MJ falling
the exact same way — zooming in on her face
with wide eyes as she plummets in slow motion.
Let's just hope MJ's fall has a
much better outcome. RIP Gwen.
It's worth noting that the
first MJ actress, Kirsten Dunst,
also had a dramatic falling scene in 2002's
"Spider-Man," though thankfully, she survived it.
Fingers crossed that the same
holds true this time around.
As virtually all of the "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" marketing material has revealed,
Tom Holland's Spidey will do battle with villains
from across multiple "Spider-Man" film franchises.
Yes, even the widely-panned "Amazing
Spider-Man" series is getting in on the action,
with Rhys Ifans' Lizard and Jamie Foxx's
Electro returning for another go-around.
The former Dr. Curt Connors looks largely the same
as he did in 2012's "The Amazing Spider-Man," but
that sentiment doesn't apply to his electrifying
companion, who's sporting an entirely new look.
When "The Amazing Spider-Man 2" hit theaters
in 2014, fans weren't very keen on Electro's
updated appearance. The glowing blue skin and
black bodysuit didn't remind fans of the fabled
Spider-Man foe in the least, echoing the visuals
of the "Ultimate Spider-Man" comics version more
than the classic incarnation that everyone loved.
Thankfully, it seems that "No Way Home" has
corrected this creative misstep by giving Max
Dillon a more Steve Ditko-inspired aesthetic.
The second trailer showed off the new-and-improved
Electro in all of his lightning bolt-masked glory,
ditching the neon blue altogether.
Of course, this begs the question:
is this version of the character even the same
as the one from the "Amazing Spider-Man" sequel,
or — if we look to the Disney+ series
"Loki" for multiverse clues — is it a
variant Electro? We'll just have to wait and see.
One of the big focuses of the new
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" trailer
is on how all of these villains are
"supposed" to die fighting Spider-Man.
“They all die fighting Spider-Man. Sorry kid.”
And with Tom Holland's Spidey being the
good guy that he is, it seems — or at least,
the trailer implies — that he wants to save
them, in some way, even as he battles them.
Perhaps this points to the antagonists of "No Way
Home" not being the old villains. What if there's
a bigger foe behind all of this? After all, Alfred
Molina's Doc Ock seems oddly mentor-like to Peter
in the trailer, which fits with his sympathetic
interpretation in "Spider-Man 2," as well.
Of course, it's important to note that
trailers for MCU films are notoriously filled
with misdirection, so who knows if any of what's
shown here is what actually happens in the film.
Another factor to consider here is the
role of Doctor Strange in the film.
While he seems to genuinely want to help
Peter fix the mess that they've made together,
he also seems to be at odds with Peter's apparent
mission to save the villains from their fate.
Will a big conflict brew between the two? Is
Doctor Strange more of an antagonist than a
supporting character, here? Again, misdirection
is a big tool in the MCU trailer playbook,
but it would be an interesting direction
for the film to take, nonetheless.
Of all the shocking and exciting new
reveals in the newest "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" trailer, we arguably
get the most from Otto Octavius.
“Wait now seriously what’s your actual name?”
However, while Doc Ock himself
is wonderfully familiar,
there's something different
about his famous tentacles.
This change appears during two scenes with Tom
Holland's Spider-Man in the trailer. When you
look closely, the tentacles seem to have a coating
of red that was not present in "Spider-Man 2,"
a color that could indicate Stark technology. The
reason for this would be unclear, but probably has
something to do with Doc Ock's arrival in the
MCU. For instance, did he steal Stark tech from
Peter's Spider-Man costume, and rework it to fit
his tentacles? If anyone could one-up Tony Stark,
it would be the brilliant Octavius. Did he
break into a Stark facility and sneak a peek
himself? Either way, an upgraded Doc Ock is
not something Spidey should be happy to see.
In the first trailer for "No Way Home,"
there were subtle hints at the villains
we would see in the film. The only sure
thing was the appearance of Doc Ock,
who showed up swinging his metal tentacles
like the good old days. Sandman, Electro,
Green Goblin, and Lizard were hinted
at, but we never saw them outright.
That all changed in the second trailer. Here, we
have been given head-on views of all four baddies,
and we even hear some dialogue
from Electro and Green Goblin.
“You’re not going to take this away from me…”
“Peter, you’re struggling.”
This surely confirms that Peter will
be taking on a group of supervillains,
long rumored to be the Sinister Six.
But if so, who is the sixth villain? For
that matter, will there be a sixth villain?
The comic book supervillain team
surely isn't called the Sinister Five,
but if there's a sixth bad guy in the
mix, then Sony and Marvel Studios have
done a fabulous job of keeping
this mystery character just that.
The biggest fan speculations online suggest the
sixth member is Vulture, Mysterio, or Venom. All
have solid chances of showing up in the film, and
maybe we'll get more than six villains, after all.
One of the most incredible shots from
the "No Way Home" trailer comes toward
the end when Peter is flying in the air
toward Electro, Sandman, and Lizard.
While we'd never rule our Spidey out, it's
an unfair fight, and it doesn't look like
Peter stands a chance. Luckily, it seems
like this is not a three-on-one battle.
Based on the position of the characters
in this scene, where they are facing,
and where they appear to be heading, it definitely
looks like this is a three on three battle.
The only villain that seems to be going for
Peter is Sandman, who is staring him straight on.
Lizard's positioning makes it looks like
he's going to breeze right past Peter,
and Electro seems to be facing upward, away
from the Web-Slinger. This very well could be
the scene when Peter and two other Spider-Men —
that would be Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield,
if the past year of rumors is correct – team
up and attack the supervillains together.
Marvel trailers are known for editing out
characters and objects, and it's highly probable
they were removed from this pivotal scene in
order to save their appearance for the final film.
The MCU's Spider-Man is no stranger to overcoming
insurmountable odds and villains of all shapes
and sizes. He has already put Adrian Toomes
— better known as The Vulture — behind bars,
and thwarted Quentin "Mysterio" Beck's evil
schemes, in addition to bravely squaring off
with Thanos multiple times. However, it's
clear that he's biting off a little more
than he can chew in "No Way Home" by standing
up to multiple super-powered rogues at once.
To make matters worse, the loud-mouthed J. Jonah
Jameson will be there to watch it all go down.
After making The Daily Bugle's editor-in-chief
a highlight in director Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man"
trilogy, J.K. Simmons returned as a new version
of J. Jonah Jameson via "Far From Home."
Instead of barking orders at his newspaper staff,
he's now a desk-pounding talk show host with a
clear dislike for Spider-Man. His 2019 comeback
was a huge surprise to moviegoers, leading them
to wonder if it was a mere one-off, or if Simmons
was in for the long haul. The second "No Way Home"
trailer supplied the answer by showing fans a
quick glimpse of the MCU's scowling, mustachioed
Jameson on a city street. Time will tell how
much screen time he'll score this time around.
Back when the first trailer for "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" came out, we got a sense of how
all the chaos in the film comes to be: Peter asks
Doctor Strange to perform a spell that will make
everyone forget who is behind Spider-Man's
mask. While the spell is being conjured,
Peter panics that Aunt May, Ned,
and MJ won't remember who he is.
“So MJ will forget everything we’ve been through?”
“Stop tampering with the spell.”
“Oh my God Ned! He’s my best friend.
My Aunt Mae should really know.”
“Stop. Talking.”
The "No Way Home" trailer seems to confirm that
the spell doesn't go quite as planned. Or does it?
MJ and Ned are peppered throughout the trailer,
and they all seem to know Peter is Spider-Man
at various points in time. Granted, no trailer is
ever put together in chronological order, so this
can't be a definite, but it does look like Doctor
Strange could not complete his spell — or that
if he did so, the loved ones who Peter did name
were somehow spared from the great memory loss.
Either way, given the fact that there's now
a bunch of multiverse madness going on, it
appears as if Peter's non-stop chattering during
the conjuring really did blow things wide open,
and it probably would have been best to
keep his mouth shut ... assuming, again,
that this isn't Marvel once again
using the trailers to misdirect us.
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
hits theaters on Dec. 17.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.